[Musica]
composizione e scomposizione
quando mi hanno detto che questo sarebbe
stato il titolo
la prima cosa che mi è venuta in mente è
stata la musica
ho pensato
sette sono le note ma infinite sono le
sue le sue combinazioni
penso che sia questa La grande magia
della musica
come diceva prima Paola
ci accompagna per tutta la vita
alcune volte quasi sempre anche prima di
nascere
è capace di farci sorridere di farci
piangere
di farci cantare danzare
la prima volta che assistette a un
concetto di musica classica era un
bambino
mi portarono nel teatro sociale della
mia città
ero molto emozionato un po' come adesso
Direi
entrai c'erano le poltroncine rosse in
fondo un palco con tante persone ognuno
con uno strumento diverso
le guardavo quando cominciarono a
suonare
Rimasi colpito dalla capacità che tutti
riuscissero a suonare la stessa melodia
in modo armonioso
mi sono chiesto Allora se sarei mai
stato capace anch'io di comporre
qualcosa di simile di così armonioso
mi viene in mente una mattina di
febbraio di quasi 20 anni fa
la telefonata che mi cambio la vita
era il mio amico Andrea un mio compagno
di classe
mi stava facendo una proposta bizzarra
di lavoro
non avrei dovuto fare il responsabile
amministrativo o commerciale e tanto
meno responsabile marketing
Come dicevano studiate economia e
commercio e fino ad allora avevo fatto
quello
mi stava chiedendo di aiutarlo a
trasformare dei luoghi in atmosfere
capaci di trasportare le persone
in una dimensione onirica
una cosa difficilissima
Non ci pensare due volte accettai
oggi alla luce di tanti anni di questo
lavoro posso dire di avere una risposta
a quella domanda che mi ero fatto quando
ero bambino sono riuscito anch'io a fare
il compositore
non di musica ma di atmosfera si
le mie sette note sono diventate gli
elementi della natura le luci colori la
musica e profumi i pavimenti e i
rivestimenti
e le mie composizioni non sono altro che
i miei sogni
che giorno dopo giorno prendono forma e
diventano realtà
la cosa più difficile è comporre in modo
armonico
queste sette note
per farlo mi lascio guidare da impulsi
profondi che abitano nel mio animo
cerco di comporli
seguendo e facendomi guidare da loro
così che il risultato sia l'esatta
espressione di quello che provo
è stato così che ho fatto fino ad oggi e
in questo modo sono riuscito a
trasformare delle scatole Bianche
in stanze capaci di trasmettere quello
che era il mio sentire
le ho dipinte di colore
ho messo delle carte alle pareti
ho posizionato le luci in punti esatti
le ho inondate di musica
e non date di profumo così che potessero
veramente dire quello che pensavo
ho cercato di indagare quali fossero gli
impulsi profondi che mi hanno guidato
fino ad oggi a creare i miei lavori e
sono giunto alla conclusione che sono
essenzialmente tre
l'ascolto
il ricordo e la natura
l'ascolto già
Perché i luoghi bisogna saperli
ascoltare
pare strano
no ha fatto
sono ricchi di storia
gli edifici che spesso mi tocca
riqualificare hanno bisogno di essere
ascoltati
Ascolto le pareti i soffitti i pavimenti
hanno storie bellissime da raccontare
e attraverso l'ascolto li scompongo per
ricomporli in una nuova armonia
in fondo c'è tradizione cultura
l'impegno di coloro che li hanno
costruiti che li hanno vissuti e che li
hanno amati
bisogna averne grande rispetto
in modo tale che la nuova composizione
diventi il collegamento la continuità
tra tradizione e innovazione
il ricordo
in francese
imparare a memoria si dice a prendere
con il cuore
trova un'espressione bellissima questa E
non solo bella ma anche Vera
se ci pensiamo
tutto quello che noi ricordiamo è quello
che si è depositato nel nostro cuore
Esiste un momento nella vita fatto di
sogni e di libertà
dove Tutto può succedere
dove se guardiamo la bellezza i nostri
occhi brillano e assaggiamo la felicità
come un gusto di gelato
ritorno spesso a visitare quel tempo
ne Raccolgo i frammenti e li semino nei
giardini e nelle stanze che Costruisco
così che coloro che li godranno potranno
assaporare il piacere di tornare
Fanciulli
ci sono immagini indelebili che da
sempre caratterizzano i miei lavori
i colori vivaci del Giardino Fiorito di
mia nonna
era davvero tanti coi fiori
l'altalena rossa che mi faceva volare
diceva mia cugina spingimi ancora di più
così vola ancora più alto
il baule in soffitta piena di monete
d'oro come quelle di Pippi Calzelunghe
in realtà era pieno di lenzuola bianche
il bosco d'estate tempestato di lucciole
che pareva davvero magico
Palazzo Vecchio a Firenze la vigilia di
Natale quella notte magica era
illuminato solo di candele ed era
davvero bellissimo
in questo non tempo
possiamo rivivere la parte più bella di
noi e forse anche quella più vera non
dobbiamo avere paura di viverla
la natura
Beh è qui che ci guarda
siamo in uno dei colossali capolavori
della natura
e quale occasione migliore per
comprenderne la grandezza e la vicinanza
la nostra essenza
penso che la natura non rappresenti solo
una cornice
una bella scenografia dove immortalare
in una bella foto momenti di vita ma è
soprattutto la migliore occasione per
ritrovare quella che è la nostra
dimensione umana e risvegliare i nostri
sensi
sempre di più nel lavoro che sto facendo
la natura assume questo ruolo
un vero e proprio rigeneratore dei sensi
in questo modo I giardini diventano il
luogo dove camminare a piedi nudi
nell'erba
assaporare cogliendole dalle piante le
fragole e i lamponi
distendersi e ad ascoltare il cinguettio
degli uccelli
all'ombra di alberi che magicamente
cambiano colore di stagione
se ci pensiamo quand'è l'ultima volta
che abbiamo fatto solo una di queste
esperienze
non dobbiamo mai dimenticare di che cosa
siamo fatti da dove veniamo
nelle mie stanze sempre di più
parlo di questo
l'orologio della natura Un tempo era
anche il nostro quello dei nostri nonni
Oggi viviamo un fuso orario accelerato
innaturale che spesso comprime e soffoca
le nostre emozioni
nelle mie stanze cerco di riportare le
lancette all'ora della natura
dove se vogliamo emozionarci abbiamo
ancora il tempo per poterlo fare
mi piace concludere
con una storia che mi ha raccontato
tempo fa una mia amica
Debussy stava seduto su una panchina a
Parigi a fianco di un suo amico poeta
gli confessò che aveva letto l'ultimo
suo poema e l'aveva trovato bellissimo
tant'è che avrebbe voluto pubblicarlo
il suo amico lo guardò e gli disse penso
di averla fatta io la sinfonia con le
mie parole
Penso che tutti noi in qualche modo
siamo dei compositori
comporre e scomporre fa parte della
natura umana
se ci pensiamo lo facciamo tutti i
giorni Quando cerchiamo di formulare una
frase o un pensiero quando prepariamo la
cena quando decidiamo che cosa indossare
il giorno dopo o progettiamo la prossima
vacanza
a volte Può risultare un processo
faticoso
ma sicuramente regala grandi
soddisfazioni
anch'io lo sono stato e lo sono anche
ora oggi un compositore di atmosfere
almeno in questa parte della mia vita
grazie
[Applauso]